خلال التمرين الدوري لحلف الناتو وصل
الغوصون الامريكيون من بنما وعملوا مع
زملائهم في النرويج تحت الماء زرعوا مواد
متفجره على خطوط الانابيب وكانوا في
انتظار الاوامر بالتفجير لكن حدثت مشكله
اخرى غير اب غير بايدن موعد التفجير وراى
ان العمليه بعد ايام من التمرين سيظهر ذلك
واشنطن سيظهر ذلك واشنطن على انها متورطه
وهنا جاء طلب جديد للبيت الابيض زرع
المتفجرات مع التفجير عن بعد في وقت لاحق
غضب الغواصون لكن كان عليهم التنفيذ
ووجدوا الحل سيتم التفجير بواسطه عوامه
سونر تسقطها طائره ميزه هذه العوامه انه
انها تصدر اشارات قويه يمكن التعرف عليها
بواسطه الاجهزه المتصله بها وبالفعل تمت
الخطه في السادس والعشرين من سبتمبر قامت
طائره استطلاع من نوع p8 وهي تابعه
للبحريه النرويجيه قامت برحله روتينيه
اسقطت عوامه سونار تحت الماء في نولد
ستريم اثنين ثم واحد بعد بضع ساعات تم
التفجير فجرت ثلاثه من اربعه خطوط في غضون
دقائق وطبعا النتيجه تسرب كميات هائله من
غاز الميثان وهو احد اقوى الغازات الدفيئه
يسخن يسخن الغلاف الجوي حوالي 30 مره اكثر
من ثاني اكسيد الكربون والكارثه على
البيئه طبعا كبيره يكفي ان تعرف ان
التقديرات تشير الى ان التسرب سوى حجم
انبعاثات غاز الميثان لمده عام كامل
ولتقليد الصوره يغطي مدينه بحجم باريس
طبعا كل هذه التسريبات نفدتها واشنطن
بينما حاولت موسكو الضغط من خلالها على
مجلس الامن الدولي